the first red gig I ever got I can tell
the story now because its ears later but
the first time I ever shot with the red
camera I did not ever have any
experience of the red camera up to that
point one of the key questions that they
asked you is have you ever shot with the
red before and just came out like a few
weeks before that I was like oh yeah of
course you know I shot with it numerous
times like music videos and blue I just
had to make up something because and
then immediately after that I was
googling the instruction manual and I
showed up to set the next day I even
called my professors as like have you
guys ever got a hand your hands under
red camera like at Miami they're like I
don't even know what you're talking
about right now because it was so new I
was like oh crap i'm gonna i'm over my
head and I got so nervous so I just said
I got so nervous that I over prepared so
I went and I read the entire manual
front to back like four times at night I
had notes taken I had like every
possible problem that we could have come
up with i looked on forums and see what
people were having overheating problems
how you fixed that blah blah blah I show
up to set the next day and I knew more
about the camera than the guy who owned
it I was like okay I'm fine and the film
turned out really cool it was a little
short film called colony directed by
friend of mine Kevin ha madani sorry
Kevin I don't think I've ever told you
the story before but I didn't know how
to use the red camera for colony and I
ended up ultimately shooting that guy's
feature film junk which is now out on
DVD so a little bit of playing the game
I mean that's a Hollywood you know story
right there like that's the kind of
stuff I heard growing up and that's this
kinda stuff I learned from reading
Robert Rodriguez's book where you just
kind of like you know out here there's
no rules you can kind of make your own
rules
you